after weeks of much hype and then false
reports that it had been stopped the
infamous caravan of Central American
migrants has arrived at the us-mexico
border hundreds of migrants have arrived
in and makeshift settlement in Tijuana
just right across the international
border from San Diego so I may try to
sneak across others plan to protect
themselves at the point of entry and
demand asylum in this country will it
work how does that work Thomas Holman is
deputy director of ice and he joins us
tonight i'm strowman thank for coming
out thank you so is that we know that
this group is coming we've been watching
on video for weeks now would it be
possible to be legal to say you are not
residents you have no legal right to
come in no you can't cross the border
well there's a couple of things we do
first of all if they're really seeking
asylum yes they just passed through a
safe nation of Mexico so if it's it's a
matter of even Guatemala Honduras trees
are in danger yes they went through
Mexico they could very easily claim
asylum there so I don't know if this is
much claiming asylum as it is get into
United States right well it's clearly a
scam obviously we know that but what can
we do about it well Congress needs to
take some action we sent a list of
legislative fix on loopholes they need
to address for instance that the
thresholds and claiming fear are so low
you know nearly 90% of people that claim
fury will get a reasonable fear yes from
the sea is because the thresholds are so
low then they go see a judge if they
ever show up and see a judge that those
approvals are much more like 30% so we
need to fix that and we need to move
those hearings up in front of an
immigration judge so they have that
formal hearing they more some do not get
fear finding so they don't have a
credible case to present and they need
to be quickly removed so how does it
work so anybody can just show up the
border without papers and say I'm in
fear for my life or I'm afraid in some
way and then they're letting to the
United States well they're held and they
will be interviewed by Citizenship and
Immigration Services but that's another
loophole for a family which most of
these people are we have a Ninth Circuit
decision that says we can only detain
family units
20 days so you know they can't possibly
have a hearing from a judge that quick
so that you man should be released you
know into the United States yes so we've
asked Congress to look at that it's
called the flora settle group we want
them to address that legislatively so if
they close these loopholes we can
control the border look last year we had
a forty five percent forty five year low
and border crossings because this
presidents taken border security
seriously he is that ice in the in the
fine men and women both will do their
jobs but then the smugglers forgot these
loopholes and now they're using these
loopholes against us so Congress needs
to act and close these loopholes so we
can do our job and secure the border so
as long as you claim fear you could not
be immediately deported you're released
into the United States
you claim fear and you get interviewed
and you can pass a very low threshold of
and mostly people being trained and
taught what to say by groups down in
Mexico come and make that claim you we
cannot remove you yet there was a those
claims had to be adjudicated
so we're basically helpless I mean we
hamstrung ourselves it sound so again if
we if we fix the loopholes we'd be in a
lot better position for instance that
the adults we are detaining until they
see a judge but the family onto the big
issue and that's what most these people
are they're the family units or that or
the children who we have certain Court
decisions that limit what we can do how
long we detain them that's what needs to
be fixed and we've presented that to
representatives on the hill months ago
so if they really want to address this
migration they can simply help us and
close these loopholes you know I bet
they don't want to miss Sherman thank
you for joining us I appreciate it thank
you for having me